what are the principles of men
communicating attractively to women
so we have broken down uh the flirting
process let's see if i can do this it's
been a long time since i've had to get
out there and do this
the first piece
is
[Laughter]
so the first piece of it is just
interest uh that we think about and
let's pretend that you're in a bar or
something uh what we're trying to avoid
in this stage is i have to go to the
bathroom i'm just bored of you and so
when we're talking about this this is
the playful stuff that we mentioned it's
a lot of the things with where do you
what do you do where are you from
finding ways to be interesting this
isn't sexy necessarily this isn't i want
to hook up with you it's just i want
this interaction to continue
the second piece that i think a lot of
guys skip out on is having genuine
standards
when you receive a letter from harvard
university that you've been accepted it
feels wonderful when you receive a
letter from the community college that
takes 100 of the people it doesn't feel
good and the truth about dating like it
or not is that we often date people to
affirm things about ourselves so when
you have no standards for this other
person and they feel like
they could have been anyone like truly
it was their shape that attracted you to
them
it doesn't
generate any sort of interest in you but
if you're indicating through interaction
for instance
if you're out at a bar or a club and
somebody is rude to a waiter or waitress
or bartender you go oh my god i can't
stand people who do that if i would you
know i don't care how beautiful or fun
or sexy you are like when i see that
kind of behavior it's a total turn off
just as an aside in a conversation
that's communicating to the person that
they care about my personality right
and now the thing is you want to have
genuine standards so
this is easier for people who have dated
and who have had you know perhaps dated
something they were very attracted to
who had personality traits that they
didn't really like
if you can go through your history and
ask yourself what are the things that
really do attract me to people that are
not sexuality or you know shape based
things what are the things that that
make me uh repulsed and list those out
and find ways to incorporate those into
conversation for instance
i have most enjoyed my relationships
with women who were incredibly
affectionate so when someone early in an
interaction says i'm a hugger i go oh my
god i'm going to love you like i'm i'm
the same way i can't stand people that
just want to like touch on the shoulder
say hello we're like high five every
time and that communicates to them that
there are things that i am selecting for
and you actually are within that
category now it is crucial here to this
is not a strategy to fake right if
you're just saying these things and
really it's like no it's you just have
the shape and the look it's not gonna
work nearly as well um
and it's also just not good for you
you're gonna wind up in the relationship
that sucks
and then the last piece is sexual
tension
and i think this is the part that is
probably most uncomfortable for a lot of
guys is being able to sit in a sexually
tense scenario which might be lingering
on eye contact with someone interaction
with a smirk on your face it might be
dancing close
without having to crack a joke
being able to manage that sexual tension
while sometimes relieving it with that
playful push-pull stuff is is
does not come natural to most people
they try to escape it as soon as they
feel it and therefore they're sitting
with that discomfort
oh yeah and it's it is tense it's it's
this in-between stage of do you like me
do i like you are we gonna kiss or are
we just look into each other's eyes and
being able to hold that and enjoy that
is something that
we talk about it takes some time to
develop but there are some things that
you can do so for instance
most people if they go on a date say you
match someone on tinder or hinge they'll
go to a bar they'll sit down on opposite
sides of a booth talk about work you
know and then they'll okay at the end of
the night
well i hope you had a good time and
there's been no sexual tension built
versus if you go to the bar you say hey
let's sit over here you sit at the bar
while you're communicating with them you
put your hand on their hand when they
make a joke you say i love that you give
them a hug you know you you know hold
their their arm while you're telling a
story to demonstrate what somebody did
you are building this sort of uh
this physical tension between the two of
you that gets more and more comfortable
and allows for those sort of close is it
happening isn't it happening
interactions and you're not putting all
the weight from going from zero to 60
with the good night kiss at the doorstep
which feels awful and it's just an
amount of like
discomfort that is that is not fun for
anybody to experience so those are those
are the sort of the buckets that we that
i think about at least when i'm talking
about it and what i try to ask guys
specifically to do because it's a
different scenario with girls is to
think about
where they are
not
uh going to the next level and it's like
oh they're just walking away from me as
i start conversations like okay let's
talk about being more interesting in
conversation or i've never actually
uh you know i'm hitting on girls and i'm
being fun and interesting but they have
a sense that i'm just a player and they
don't want to talk to me it's like well
you've got no standards and then so
going through those using that as a
diagnostic tool is is something that we
do
i think guys are probably quite fearful
about running out of stuff to say as
well have you got strategies for small
talk yeah so uh one there's there's a
couple of different videos in terms of
women uh specifically in flirting
scenarios this is the hardest things my
brain is like this and you've seen in
this interaction
i'm a logistical person when you ask me
a question i want to answer it literally
the best thing for small talk is to
recognize that especially on a date or
in a borrower club they just want a vibe
you don't have to have topics it's not
about not [ __ ] podcast work yeah it's
it's a podcast it's not supposed to be
that it's supposed to be fun playful
world building so uh
you know if she says oh my god
like you went to jamaica i studied
abroad there be like oh my god fantastic
after this bar we're going to the
airport we're going to get on a plane
we're going to go scuba diving we'll be
there tomorrow morning we're going to
have to fund this so somehow i don't
know i'm going to have to take up a job
selling lucy cigarettes
on the street whatever you're just like
just this playful
world building is a way that men tend
not to instinctively communicate what do
you mean by world building
uh what i just created was almost an
improvisational comedy sk scenario like
we're going to go here here's what's
going to happen obviously none of this
is real this is this is i'm definitely
not going to sell lucy cigarettes to
fund a plane ride for tomorrow but when
you can build these fake
fun obviously not real fantasy scenarios
that people participate in and sometimes
men do this with their with their good
friends when they're all on a group of
people you know that would be like if
blah blah blah oh my god when you do
that with women in fun ways that tends
to
uh set the vibe to be this fun flirty
thing that she can contribute to and say
well we're not going to stay in the same
room tonight be like perfect i'm going
to get a i'm going to have the penthouse
and you could sleep in you know the
water closet or whatever and no i don't
want to sleep in the water closet so
these these are the types of things that
are ridiculous that most men would never
think about doing in conversation but
that are genuinely fun once you
try on this new style of of conversing
now of course
there's still going to be time for
what do you do where you from what's
your work but especially in a bar
nightclub scenario which is i think what
i'm tending towards more
if you lead with here's my cool job i
work at goldman sachs that's incredibly
boring i can't tell you the number of
guys in new york i saw who started by
handing out business cards instead of
doing this fun stuff first and then
they'll be like who are you
tell me about yourself and then at that
point the goldman sachs thing actually
comes in as a patent interrupt and
you're like oh holy [ __ ] like he's
actually funny and interesting and he's
prepared to sell loose cigarettes
and he's got a job at an investment bank
yes exactly and the best way then when
you're talking about you know okay i
work in investment bank is to speak to
your values again people want to know
your vibe and your values not just the
logistics of what you do so if you say i
work at goldman sachs
a much stronger way is to think what
drove me hopefully it's not just a sense
of greed but like you know i grew up
poor and i always wanted to be able to
take care of my mom and family so like
you know i don't want to be an
investment banker for the rest of my
life but it's helping me to one day buy
a house for my mom like that if if true
so attractive so
so much more engaging than i'm a banker
at goldman sachs so if you're setting a
vibe or sharing your values those are
two very strong modes of conversation to
be in compared to just answering
questions logistically honestly
yeah that's an interesting one man i am
i'm interested to find out what you
think most men go wrong when approaching
women and if there's girls that are
watching they can put some of their
nightmare scenarios down in the comments
below as well women have a very
different understanding of this because
they're when they think what goes wrong
with men they're selecting for the men
that have approached them right and so
they're going oh they were way too pushy
way too forward they said this goofy
thing they did some r nice guys stuff
where they told me like they could be my
boyfriend and i'd never have to go cold
the truth is most guys are are not in
that category they're not walking up to
you they're thinking about it uh
but not doing it right so that's that's
by far 99.9 that's 99.9
is not engaging in conversation uh so
that's definitely the the thing that
most of them do wrong though when women
think about what most men do wrong
they're going to go to the horror
stories of the 0.1 percent that just
come in like complete arrogant asses uh
so yeah it's it's not
it's disqualifying yourself before
before you've spoken to someone uh and
there's a hundred different ways to
speak to someone mentalities that can
help but
uh going in with a vibe of curiosity and
again flirt with the world i think one
of the things that men do wrong is that
they try to be these snipers which is
like these boring people who walk
through life not talking to anyone not
engaging with the cashier and then
they're going to see the most beautiful
woman at the bar who is surrounded by
people who want to speak to her and
they're going to go now i'm going to
turn it on yeah by the power of gray
school they decide to pick up a [ __ ]
right this it's time to turn it on it's
time to do it yeah and then they he they
hulk out and and just do it that's not
how it's ever been with me i haven't
seen it done that way it it's by
flirting with the world it's by
recognizing that the person that you
should flirt with is the next person you
interact with and whether that's
someone in your apartment building as
you're taking the elevator who is an
older gentleman like being that outgoing
fun friendly person setting a vibe
goofing off
and then just happening to be near the
person that you're interested in is
going to be much much more powerful
because it's not something that you've
got to like gear up for it's something
that is going to be habituated into the
way that you're used to speaking with
people it won't feel like such a stretch
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you